even if you don't know her by name you
most likely have seen Frida Kahlo's
paintings before she is the Mexican
woman with a balls unibrow wearing a
flower crown and brightly colored
clothing Carly was physically disabled
her entire adult life yet she loved
herself enough to be her own muse years
before her time she challenged society's
expectations and was able to create
surrealist works of art that examines
the inner workings of the human soul on
today's Maya graphics we're gonna tell
you the story of the great artist Frida
Kahlo Magdalena Carmen Frida Kahlo
Calderon was born on July the 6th 1907
in koyukon Mexico her family lived in a
blue house appropriately named La Casa
Azul her father was a German
photographer and her mother was Spanish
and a Native American
Frieda's father used her as a model in
his photography studio and it was during
this time that she learned how to beat
photogenic even from an early age she
had an incredibly intense gaze into the
camera lens by the time she was 17 she
was fed up with wearing all of the
frilly dresses that her father put her
in and she chose to pose in a man suit
during one of their family photos which
was of course completely frowned upon in
the 1920s as a child she suffered from
polio and one leg was permanently
shorter than the other but she never let
that stop her from being adventurous she
climbed trees she danced and she played
outside with their friends in 1922 she
began attending the National proprietary
school in Mexico City with the intention
of becoming a doctor but when she was 18
years old she was on a bus heading to
school when it collided with a tram car
during the crash a metal handrail
impaled her body going straight through
her torso to the points where the rod
was sticking out the other ends she had
also fractured her spine in multiple
places as well as got a broken pelvis
hips collarbone both of her legs and a
few ribs she had lost so much blood that
the doctors didn't think she would make
it by no small miracle Fria Kahlo and
miraculously survived the tram accidents
Frida lay in a hospital bed while her
entire body healed the doctor told her
that because of where the metal rod had
impaled her it was unlikely that she
would ever be able to get
pregnant even after several operations
she was now disabled and the injuries
would cause her to paint for the rest of
her life her boyfriend Alejandro Gomez
arias had been on the bus as well but he
survived the crash with only minor
injuries
when she wrote letters to him she often
asked questions like what will my life
be like 30 years from now and she knew
that the rest of her existence would be
an uphill battle as you can imagine her
entire body had been put into casts and
she was told not to leave a hospital bed
for several months during this time when
she was bedridden her father helped her
set up a specially made easel to hang
over a bed so that she could spend her
days painting since she could knock
outside everything Frida painted was
from a memory she was painting her own
surrealist versions of reality along
with symbols of Mexican religion and
culture Frida also painted and sketched
herself in order to express her pain
through her drawings there is no doubt
that even though her body had been
weakened her mind was still incredibly
strong and that helped keep her going
Frida once wrote feat what do I need you
for when I have wings to fly as time
went on she chose to no longer groom
herself the way women were expected to
she was trying to heal from the
accidents since there was no time to
tweeze her eyebrows or shave her upper
lip when she painted self-portrait in a
velvet dress she caps all of those
details true to real life even though
she could have easily painted out what
society deemed as imperfections this
level of honesty was incredibly brave
even by today's standards when you think
about how many selfies are taken with
snapchat filters and faced you but this
point Frida Kahlo was just happy to be
alive and she began to embrace the body
that she was born with once she left the
hospital pre don't return to school but
she was now in a wheelchair while her
friends were still spending time with
her they wanted to continue living their
young and vibrant lives and they just
drifted in different directions Shayla
hundred Gomez arias they broke up and
she decided to focus on the life that
she could cultivate which was her mind
and her art she also joins her
University's chapter of the Mexican
Communist Party and it would set her on
a course that would change the rest of
her life
in order to understand the full story of
Frida Kahlo's epic love we need to get
back to when she was 15 years old a
famous artist named Diego Rivera was
painting a mural at the Simon Bolivar
amphitheater in the National proprietary
school Frida would sneak in to watch him
she was fascinated by his work and he
completely inspired her to become a
great artist like most teenagers with a
crush she swooned to her best friends
about how great he was and said that one
day she would marry him and have his
babies but then when he left the
painting to take a break she put soap
all over his ladder and teased him when
he slipped and fell this was enough him
to notice her but not enough him to
reciprocate her feelings of course after
all he was 35 at the time and from his
perspective this was just a kid he was
trying to distract him but it couldn't
help notice that she has an unusual
dignity and self-assurance and there was
a strange fire in her eyes so let's fast
forward to 1928 Frida was 21 years old
and it had been three years since their
accidents through an intense amount of
physical therapy she finally had learned
to walk again but it was still necessary
for her to wear back braces and corsets
that were made of plaster in order to
keep her spine straight still though
sometimes the pain was just too much to
bear and she would have to use a
wheelchair she was all grown up now and
in the six years since she had last saw
Rivera she had become a beautiful young
woman even though it had been years she
would still visit his famous murals
around the city and followed the
progress of his artistic career she
heard that he was painting another mural
at Mexico cities and ministry of
education so she began showing up every
day
this time she sat quietly and
respectfully watching and studying him
as he painted one day Frida Kahlo
bravely approached diego rivera and told
him that she had admired his talent for
years she explained that she was an
aspiring artist and wanted to know his
opinion of her work at first he did not
recognize her but once she explains the
story of the soap on the ladder he
instantly made the connection because
she still had that same fire in her eyes
Frida invited him over to the Casa Azul
where he could see all of her work in a
studio after seeing Frida's Artie told
her in my opinion no matter how
difficult it might be for you you must
continue to paint while he was in her
home
could see how much joy and passion she
had for painting and it rejuvenated his
love for his own work he said I did not
know it then but Frieda had already
become the most important fact of my
life they began to spend more time
together and went on several dates a few
days later he kissed her for the first
time this it was just the beginning of a
relationship that would last for the
rest of her life Diego Rivera and Frida
Kahlo were married in 1929 and they
continued to be one another's muses
their relationship inspired one another
to keep creating more and more amazing
works in one of her letters to him she
wrote Diego I'd like to paint you but
there are no colors because there are so
many and my confusion the tangible form
of my great love
[Music]
Frida and Diego were both part of a
group of artists and intellectuals who
would later be labeled as part of the
mexicana Dada movement which was a
reinvigorated sense of national pride
instead of trying to copy European
artists they wanted to create a new art
style that's identified Mexican culture
aside from their mutual love of art
Frida and Diego discussed politics at
great length Diego was so well known
that he became a political activist in
the Mexican Communist Party and was
often painting Soviet symbolism into his
works of art Diego Rivera was already
wealthy from the sales of his arts and
as the years went on the rest of the
world was beginning to respect and
appreciate his mexicana Dada style as
well he was invited to paint several
murals across the United States at the
time no one was paying much attention to
Frida Kahlo's work because she was just
the wife of this far more famous artist
in 1931 they were living in New York
City and she was miserable with the vibe
of the town in a letter to her friend
she wrote I'm not painting or doing
anything I just like the high society
here and feel a little rage against all
these fat cats since I've seen thousands
of people in terrible misery for years
Rivera was sniffing communist
iconography into his murals across the
United States but they mostly went
unnoticed in 1933 Rivera painted a mural
that was meant to go in the lobby of the
Rockefeller Center called man at the
crossroads but he clearly included the
image of Lenin once they spotted this
the officials demanded that he remove
all communist imagery but he refused to
do so and the painting remains
unfinished
after spending several years traveling
Diego had an architect build them two
separate houses that were side-by-side
and connected by a bridge so that they
could live together and still have each
of their own private art studios
eventually the couple returned to
Frida's childhood home the casa azul
which she inherited from our parents in
1937 they met the Communist
revolutionary Leon Trotsky who was
living in exile since they were already
huge supporters of the USSR they invited
him to live with them in the Casa Azul
for years there was an ongoing rumor
that free carlo and leon trotsky were
having an affair she even gave him one
of her self-portraits with a note that
said to Leon Trotsky with all my love I
dedicate this painting the rumor about
their affair it was published over and
over again so many times that it was
eventually
taken as historic fact it was even
included in the plot of the 2002 movie
Frida starring Salma Hayek however it
was later discovered that the affair may
have never actually taken place in his
last will and testament Diego Rivera
strictly forbid any of his personal
paperwork to be released to the public
until fifty years after his death he
ordered that all of their private
letters and documents should be hidden
inside of their bathroom wall at La Casa
Azul so when they were unveiled in 2007
the public finally got to read the
letters between Carlo and Trotsky while
it's true that they frequently wrote to
one another and spent a great deal of
time together in their home these hidden
letters revealed that the correspondence
between Carlo and Trotsky it was
strictly platonic
in fact Frida Carlo spent most of her
letters supporting her husband trying to
convince Trotsky that he deserved to
have a more prominent role in the
Communist Party she even called Trotsky
out on his behavior as being egotistical
and revealed that she did not like him
at all she once wrote I observed that
whenever there was a discussion of any
kind and Diego gave his opinion you
always took it with a certain irony and
doubtfulness of its truthfulness this
kind of irony in time gets on one's
nerves
[Music]
throughout her life Frieda had to
undergo a total of 30 operations one of
their most famous paintings the broken
column depict sound she truly felt
inside she was constantly being out of
the hospital and she became very good
friends with that doctor there were a
series of letters that revealed that she
became pregnant with Diego Rivera's
child this game is a shock to her as
she'd been told that she would never be
able to have children
however the daughter urged her to get an
abortion because he explains that her
body would not be able to take the
pregnancy to full-term
however the guilts of the abortion it
was overwhelming when she got pregnant a
second time in 1932 she tried to keep
the baby even if it meant breaking bones
and sacrificing her own body but the
scarring in her uterus was too extensive
to bring the pregnancy determined Freda
supplement on run of her body corsets
Freda painted the Communist symbol over
her heart and an image of a fetus over a
belly to symbolize the two unborn
children that she had lost she wore it
like a Medal of Honor underneath her
clothes since she was disabled and in
near constant pain Freda could not fully
satisfy Diego Rivera's libido he was
also a celebrity so there was no
shortage of female attention Freda was
fully aware of his infidelity but she
had also become totally dependent on his
care and addicted to his love and
affection instead of divorcing him she
took the opportunity to have an affair
with the photographer Nicolas Marie and
she also experimented with her sexuality
by having affairs with several women she
became good friends with the actress
Josephine Baker ins the artist Georgia
O'Keeffe the latter was famous for
making paintings of flowers that
actually look but you know what they
look like Frida and Diego would often
throw parties at their home and the
famous Mexican musician
hvala Vargas was invited to one of them
after seeing Frida for the first time
Vargas said she was like a vision when I
saw her face her eyes I thought she was
from another world the two became very
close and had an affair that lasted much
longer than the other flings that she'd
had with women during an interview
available explains that she truly did
love Frida Kahlo and she drew all of her
artistic inspiration from her Frieda's
favorite song was called La Llorona
which is based on the terrifying Mexican
legend of the weeping woman
however Frida Kahlo was still in love
with Diego and she was never going to
leave her husband for
woman this relationship of unrequited
love was breaking young Vargas heart she
wrote the song
Paloma Negra or black dove in it you
could clearly hear the anguish in her
voice even though she claimed to be fine
with their mutual unfaithfulness Diego
Rivera crossed the line when he accepted
with her sister this led to a divorce in
nineteen forty one month later she cut
off all of her hair and painted a
self-portrait dressed in one of Diego's
suits at the top of the painting she
included a bar of musical notes and the
lyrics of a famous Mexican folk song
about falling out of love unfortunately
though love is an incredibly complex
emotion and it doesn't just turn off
overnight she expressed her inner
turmoil with a double self-portrait
called the two Frida's showing her past
self on the Left where she was wearing a
white dress symbolizing her past purity
and innocence the young Frida had her
heart ripped out of her chest and she
gave it to the Frida on the right who
was older and much stronger but she
still held on to the memory of Diego by
holding his portrait in her hands even
though she was clearly in a toxic
relationship Frida and Diego felt that
they could not live without one another
and they got remarried less than a year
after their divorce there is a saying
that great art comes from pain and in a
way this betrayal actually helps to
further along her solo career in 1947
the two Frida's painting was purchased
by the National Institute of Fine Art in
Mexico City for four thousand pesos
which is roughly a thousand dollars
after modern-day inflation that's closer
to eleven thousand three hundred and
ninety nine dollars seemed that finally
the art world was beginning to recognize
her talents and she was no longer just
the wife of Diego Rivera
[Music]
in 1953 frida kahlo
finally had her very first art exhibit
but a health it was declining
she was so physically weakened in pain
that a doctor advised her to stay in bed
even when she was sick her soul was
still strong enough to demands that she
must go to her art show that's nice the
patrons of the Arts received the
grandest entrance they had ever seen as
Frida Kahlo's four-poster bed was
carried in on a stretcher by a group of
men she was all done up in a beautiful
dress as well as makeup and a crown of
flowers lay on her head sadly though her
illness got worse and that same year she
contracted gangrene in one of her legs
and it had to be amputated even so she
tried to stay strong and decorated her
prosthetic leg to make it beautiful but
she was already in constant pain from
her earlier injuries losing her leg made
it even more unbearable she learned how
to walk again and even tried to go
dancing in a new leg her doctor
prescribed her pain medication to help
dull her senses but it was still a life
of near-constant misery on July the 7th
1954 she turned 47 years old her friends
and family they threw her a birthday
celebration there were over a hundred
people there for the first time in
months she dressed in her finest clothes
put on makeup and Don's the flowers in
her hair again but once the party was
over and the guests went home she was
left alone to face her reality perhaps
she knew that from then on things were
only going to get worse her health was
declining and she struggled to
accomplish even the smallest daily tasks
just a few days after a party on July
the 12th Carlo is lying in a childhood
bedroom in the castle she sketched an
image of an angel with black wings in a
journal she wrote I hope the exit is
joyful and I hope to never come back
Freda the next morning on July the 13th
Diego found her she died of a pulmonary
embolism most speculate this was caused
by overdosing on her pain medication and
that she chose to met suicide her family
visited the home and helped prepare the
body before it was taken to the Palace
of Fine Art for a public viewing and
funeral de Rivera was in such shock he
refused to believe that she was truly
dead he got into an argument with a
doctor refusing to bury her until he had
a substantial proof that she was truly
gone afterwards they draped her coffin
in a black cloth with red flowers Diego
sister Don draping the communist symbol
over a coffin as well over the course of
a lifetime frida kahlo created a total
of 143 paintings and 55 of them were
self-portraits she became the first
Latin American woman to have one of her
paintings displayed in the Louvre museum
in Paris she has become such a
well-known artist that people simply
refer to her as Frida even though she
has gone she is anything but forgotten
today her work has become more relevant
than ever her works and personal letters
are considered to be so valuable that
they sell for millions of dollars at
auction and in recent years there is a
strong resurgence of appreciation for
Frida Kahlo and she truly cemented
herself in history as a true Mexican
icon so I really hope you found their
video interesting if you did please do
give us a thumbs up below and don't
forget to subscribe we've got brand new
videos just like this four times per we
can hit that notification bell so you
actually find out about them also why
not check out my other channel called
top tens you'll find a link to that
below and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]